kathy wood is one of the best-known
investors across wall street her entire
thesis is to invest in disruptive
companies to look out five in ten years
not worry about day-to-day price
movements she's been doing this for a
very very long time and arkan vest her
asset management firm has grown in
popularity especially with the younger
generation that tends to be much more
sympathetic to many of the technology
companies that have become so popular
over the last couple of years kathy wood
was on national television just recently
and she talked about two specific things
that i thought were interesting the
first is that she says that we're in a
recession and the second is that
inflation has been much stickier much
more persistent than she previously
thought here's exactly what kathy was
talking about in this clip when you
think though about the last year and you
think about your approach what is the
lesson in it we were wrong on one uh one
thing and that was inflation being as
sustained as it has been supply chain
i can't believe it's taken more than two
years and uh russia's invasion of
ukraine of course we couldn't have seen
that but i think that it has set us up
for deflation we think we're in a
recession and we think a really big
problem out there is inventories the
likes of the increase uh of which i've
never seen this large in my career and
i've been around for 45 years
we're talking about the best managed
companies in the world if you're talking
about walmart and target they know how
to manage supply chain so if they have
problems we think there are a lot more
problems and then the other thing that's
going on is the consumer is railing
against these price increases consumer
sentiment is
down to record low levels below 0809
below 80 and 81 i had just started my
career and inflation and interest rates
were in the double digits 15 20
and most interestingly consumer
sentiment of the in the highest income
groups
is lower
than in the the lowest income groups and
those the latter group is being you know
tormented by food and energy prices
which are really a regressive tax
increase there now one of the
interesting critiques of kathy and her
strategy is if you think that we're in a
recession and potentially going further
and further down this economic downturn
why would you be buying innovation
stocks or growth in technology companies
well the reason is because markets are
forward-looking kathy isn't buying them
because of the current situation she's
looking out five or ten years and she's
saying where will economic growth come
from where will value accrue over the
coming years and technology and
innovation is one of those areas it's
the most disruptive part of the entire
stock market and so ultimately she's
saying regardless of where we are today
recession or good times i want to invest
in the things that over the coming years
will end up accruing that value that's
one of the key attributes of great
investors is understanding that you're
not actually buying assets based on the
current environment instead what you
have to do is anticipate what's going to
happen in the future humans are really
bad at predicting the future but trying
to increase the probabilities of your
bets ends up actually leading to more
wins than losses and so when you see an
investor like kathy wood buying these
disruptive technologies and these growth
and tech stocks don't ask yourself why
would you be buying some sort of growth
and innovation when there's a recession
and potential deflation
instead ask yourself what does kathy
think is going to happen over the next
five years and likely then all of a
sudden the investments that she's making
today make a lot more sense markets are
forward-looking and so remember buying
assets today based on today's
environment usually just means that you
haven't thought about what's likely to
happen over the coming years hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time